what's up guys bang bang this following
conversation is with Sean Douglas the
CEO of Amber data in the conversation we
talk about the infrastructure for Market
data we talk about what they're seeing
out there with their customers after the
FTX Fallout and all of the contagion and
we also look at exactly how they're
Gathering the data what they're doing
with it and how they present it to those
individual customers this was a great
Deep dive on Market infrastructure
specifically around data is that
something you're interested in you'll
love this episode all right let's get
into my conversation with Sean I hope
you guys enjoyed this one all right guys
bang bang I've got Sean here with me
Sean I thought a great place to start
would just do a super deep dive on what
the hell infrastructure for Market data
is uh and a great place there is just
like what is the market data what data
are you guys going to get and how
exactly are you gathering this data yeah
absolutely so um you know Amber data
what we do is we provide Market
infrastructure which spans both
fundamental data or accounting data
which is on chain
um as well as what's happening on on
centralized trading venues around the
world so whether that be spot markets
derivative markets options venues what
is happening across you know the top
blockchain networks every D5 protocol
every decks uh what's happening who uh
who are the liquidity providers what's
their
um what are their positions you know are
they making money or not so at Amber
data what we do is we provide that
connectivity into every centralized
trading venue as well as
um visibility into all activity on chain
and across all of the protocols and
um we provide that which is you know
pretty difficult to do and very
expensive and very complex and we make
that simple so anybody in the financial
services value chain can easily uh get
access to that data and drilled data
power to applications on top of that and
so how are you actually going to get it
like is what technology have you all
built where are they getting it from and
then what are you doing to synthesize or
massage it before you show it to
customers yeah absolutely so um we
connect into centralized exchanges via
uh their apis
um and ingest that data Real Time by
websocket or fixed protocol
um and then ingest the you know event
level order books which is really what's
happening in the price Discovery process
real time we aggregate that into open
high low close volume reference rates
single asset indices what have you that
gives them context and then we connect
into really the 30 largest trading
venues around the world which is you
know billions of dollars a day uh in
trading activity and we ingest normalize
that to us to uh all the same time
stamps so people can understand globally
what's happening with with spreads and
Market depth and price Discovery and
then on the on-chain data
um we run blockchain nodes multiple
archive nodes across every major
blockchain as well as well as catch all
the ephemeral data uh the pending pool
what's happening in in the mempool
um and then parse every transaction
against an ABI to understand really
what's happening in those smart
contracts what are the the crypto
economic mechanisms what are the
incentives what are the inputs what are
the outputs and we create a proprietary
time series from that data and we store
all of that in you know AWS and and
other Cloud providers uh and then we
make and provide that data to our
customers via apis so that they can
build their applications on now why is
that hard and why is that expensive and
isn't all this data free that's these
are the questions that people ask and
and a lot of the centralized exchange
data like order book data for example
liquidation data is not even retained by
the exchanges so once it's gone it's you
know it's gone so what we do is we
capture that so high frequency trading
firms market makers uh you know
Regulators who want to understand
behavior on exchanges can analyze that
data train their models
um and make that data actionable
um from an on-chain data perspective
it's incredibly complex to be able to
get this data one and then take the raw
blockchain data which is pretty much
useless
um as a as a as itself and parse that
and and make that so it's it's
information
um which means that you need to run
multiple blockchain nodes you need to
parse that data and then you need to
build that into time series that people
can build applications around
so it's uh once you gather the data uh
and you guys kind of uh manipulate slash
massage synthesize however you want to
think about that how are you showing it
to the customers is this through uh an
interface is this all API driven like
how are they actually ingesting it on
their side or if I think of like the
other side of the product yeah so if you
what you think about it is we
provide that we we provide that data to
our customers via restful apis or by
real-time data via websockets or by a
fixed protocol and then they build
Financial applications on top of that
whether that be a front office trading
portfolio management research
application or a middle office
um treasury or risk
um application or back office fund
Administration tax compliance power the
data to talk to your Auditors
um so they build on top of our apis and
then additionally we have um recently
acquired Genesis volatility which is was
the leading provider for options and
derivatives analytics uh and we've have
so we now have a analytics platform that
provides visibility into derivatives
um options and on-chain defy uh data and
we'll be extending that that use case so
for people who don't code they have the
ability to understand what is happening
in markets from a volatility from a skus
from open interests from kind of what's
moving where and what are the
relationships
much of this is uh used for trading like
people are ingesting the data
specifically for trading or what most
people would think of either high
frequency hedge funds things like that
versus other types of use cases like
what are the customers actually doing
with the data
yeah so I would say that we really focus
on Financial Services whether that be
the banks that are building Structured
Products or derivatives non-deliverable
forwards Etc to the proprietary trading
firms and market makers uh that are that
are building back testing their strategy
to identifying opportunities quantifying
risk and then actually programmatically
act upon that to the uh risk
applications for example say your major
exchange and you hold a bunch of stable
coins you want to know what's the
variance from Peg on those stable coins
um what are the what's the circulating
Supply versus the total Supply you know
are these things behaving as expected
because do you carry them as treasury
assets or are they risk assets you know
we've seen a couple stable coins unpeg
and then they weren't as stable as as
people thought
um so we give people that visibility
we'll also from a risk perspective
enable people to understand their
counterparties these on-chain behavior
and activity to understand hey I'm a
lending desk and I've loaned somebody
usdc are they just taking and using that
or are they taking in re-hypothecating
that and adding leverage it's not like a
bank when they loan you money to buy a
house
um you know that they bought a house in
in digital assets they can you can lend
somebody usdc and then they can lever
that up 20 times and put it in something
that's uh it may change the risk profile
and of how you perceive that that
customer and then the last piece is we
facilitate all of the trading that
happens on this and then the the market
surveillance and and understanding
what's going on but we also you have to
account for this people have to be able
to do pay their taxes do their
accounting
um provide good reporting talk to
Auditors talk to regulators and people
you know are using our data to to do all
those use cases as well so it's really
spans the entire Financial Service
Services value chain from front to Mid
to back office what's unique about you
all is that you kind of sit in the
middle here right you're going and
you're getting a bunch of different data
whether it's through the centralized
exchange order books whether it's
through on chain data kind of all those
different inputs if you will and then
you're actually presenting it to a bunch
of different customers sometimes even
some of the customers that you're
getting data from you're presenting back
the data uh combined with other data
sets um and so you're almost like in
this like middle uh ground where there's
a two-sided Marketplace and you all are
like a broker to some degree uh or at
least that's kind of how I Elementary
you know think about it what are the
advantages and disadvantages of sitting
in the middle there like that right it's
clear you have a lot of insights but are
there disadvantages or are there other
types of advantages that maybe aren't as
obvious to people
yeah I think from an advantaged
perspective
um you know we are barely very uniquely
positioned in the market where we have
the smartest people and tried Vibe
whether there be Banks or or you know
people like NASDAQ or or you know a city
or or you know hardcore
um crypto natives
um like you know Galaxy or you know
pentairs of the world where we're
uniquely positioned where we see you
know very demand you know a
demands from crypto natives as well as
demands from traditional Financial
Services players so that we've been able
to develop a very unique product
offering now and what that does is it
gives us this we can see anything that's
happening on any centralized exchange or
in any on-chain activity say you're
interested in you're a traditional
Financial Services firm you're like hey
what is this Ave lending Market you know
there's six billion dollars of total
value lock today you know you know
working across seven different networks
uh trading in you know 13 different
markets this looks like a banking
business this looks like you know a
yield generating asset how do how do I
look at that and how do I understand
that and so we really have this unique
vantage point that we can help whether
they be traditional Financial Services
firms that are moving into the crypto
space or hardcore crypto natives
understand quantify activity and um you
know or say same goes for participation
across the dexes so you know uniswap has
I think three billion dollars total
value locked and you know trades you
know billions who you know recently to
20 billion dollars a day in in swaps
between tokens it's it's really unique
to be able to not just have Market data
but also have the on-chain Telemetry to
be able to see
um all the activity that's happening and
you can also start to see now that FTX
is gone you're starting to see flows
from you know they pretty much the only
place that you could trade dollar
denominated derivatives on crypto other
than CME
um to that flow starting to move to you
know GMX and dydx and other
um you know derivative platforms so I
would say that the unique position we
have is we
um have the ability to see anything that
is happening across the entire crypto
economy now the disadvantage to that is
what we do is incredibly expensive
um and costs us you know tens of
millions of dollars to build and you
know that's that's the advantage that we
bring to our customers is they don't
need to spend tens of millions of
dollars to create the market
infrastructure to be able to extract the
accounting fundamentals and uh market
price Discovery process
we we make that easy for you know less
than the cost of an engineer uh you know
a year they can literally get access to
you know years of developed development
and you know tens of millions of dollars
in investment
when you think about the business that
you all have built
um what's the biggest risk for you all
whether it is operationally building the
company whether it's something in the
market whether it's something in terms
of the quality of the data you get like
how do you evaluate where are the risks
and then what are you all doing to
mitigate those risks
yeah so from a risk perspective it's
evolved a lot we've been doing this for
five years now you know it used to be
like was crypto going to be here forever
and that's no longer a question uh it's
definitely not going away and we're just
seeing institutions continue to lean in
I think there's
um
the the risks to our business are
you know which how heavily do we invest
in in fast-moving early developing
protocols because some of these things
you can invest in hundreds of thousands
of dollars in building an
instrumentation then boom they go away
you know like Solana right now what's
what's the future for Solana it's hard
to tell
um you know but three weeks ago Solana
was booming and there was hundreds of
developers and Lisbon in a in a lot of
hackathon sponsored by FTX so you know
you can you can make some bets and then
the landscape drastically changes uh
that's a you know biggest risk for us
from a regulatory perspective crypto is
not going away we're seeing additional
institutional you know more institutions
moving in now
um than I think people realize and from
a regulatory perspective
they're always going to need data and
they're going to need insights and we
have visibility and Telemetry that
doesn't exist in traditional financial
markets so you know I don't think
regulation is a risk I don't think that
um you know the the space going away is
a risk I really think that our biggest
risks are what bets do we make and and
you know not getting over our skis in
one area or another and so that we focus
where the market is at and where it's
going and and uh you know not squander
our our scarce resources what are you
all seeing in the market right now
obviously we've seen the Fallout from
FTX there's a lot of contagion in the
market other companies and uh various
funds are succumbing to kind of that
contagion what are you all seeing is
demand going up is it going down is it
kind of just the same are you seeing
different types of customers come in are
you seeing more of the same what just
give me kind of an update in terms of uh
what does your view of the world look
like post some of this chaos
yeah so I think
um what we're seeing is that more
sophisticated players
um that have been perhaps a little on
the sidelines and we're building a
longer longer terms plan have now come
back and said hey this is a great time
to enter this is a great price point to
enter
um however
they're they're
um
posture has moved from a fomo that they
were going to miss markets to now let me
quantify this opportunity and quantify
this risk and I need the data to
understand this and I need to to
understand counterparties and flows and
behavior and and what are these these
mechanisms behind some of these digital
assets to incentivize participation and
what do those cash flows look like so
it's actually great for us
um now we obviously have you know the
last six months has been uh quite a ride
we obviously saw you know the Terra Luna
you know deep pegging
um and you know financial markets or
hostile environments and when you know
pegs can do get challenged and even in
traditional markets and you saw from
that highly leveraged firms like three
arrows blow up which caused contagion to
each of the lending protocols then not
lending protocols lending firms uh
blockify Celsius everybody knows the the
list of of uh characters there we
re-learned about counterparty risks so I
think what we're seeing one of the
takeaways from that is people are very
concerned about custody and I think that
this positions of the large Banks who
have custody businesses or or developing
custody businesses to
um be Banks and custody and hold assets
for people and I think people are
looking to
um many of the Trad five players to
potentially
um help them on their custody uh
Journeys we um with FTX it's unfortunate
um they were definitely the darling and
in many regards but I think most of the
Regulators that we speak to in many of
the large financial institutions are
looking at this more like an MF Global
or perhaps an Enron and they're saying
hey this is a and this is an event but
this is not the industry and um I think
people are already starting to move past
that and interesting we're starting to
see many of the traditional uh us-based
exchanges looking at this as an
opportunity to lean in and perhaps
acquire some of those assets from FTX
out of firestail or
um some of the the licensing or or use
this as an opportunity to lean in
um and the same thing goes for banking
we're now starting to see some of our
banking customers developing stable
coins that are that are FX pairs we're
starting to see uh non-deliverable
forwards contracts which are effectively
Perpetual Futures contracts traded by
Banks to give their customers access to
digital assets for example Bitcoin
without having to worry about having to
you know the custody components if they
don't have a custody business they're
now doing non-deliverable forwards
um we're uh we're also seeing
traditional Financial Services firms may
have been in financial services for 200
years started to build Structured
Products around some of these assets
because they know how to build uh
Structured Products and security so
we're really seeing
um a I would say a Phoenix rising from
the ashes on on the FTX uh front and I
think that we will come out of this
stronger better with better risk and and
likely we'll see regulation uh where you
I could I could Envision a world where
it's no longer okay for the exchange to
be in exchange a broker dealer and to do
custody I think that that will probably
we could see regulation there and then
we also see Geographic
um differences in strategy as well I
think London in the UK right now in
Singapore are are both making plays to
be the place for digital assets to uh to
to to to operate and grow
um so I think that you know there's a
lot of of positive things that come out
from you know a pretty horrible six
months in digital assets got it when you
start to look out at the market over the
next call it you know six to 12 months
uh kind of going into 2023 and maybe
towards the end of that year what are
the big things on the horizon for uh
amber data and then what do you expect
uh to be some of the milestones for the
industry
yeah I think that right now what we're
hearing and have been hearing for the
last year is derivatives derivatives
derivative derivatives you know if you
think about traditional financial
markets there's about 480 billion
dollars a day that are trading in
derivatives
um in the equities markets and and uh
same goes for the FX markets which are
just gargantuan right I think that
you'll see more and more sophisticated
players come in and then not want just
straight Delta exposure uh you know
Longshore of for crypto they're going to
want to leverage derivatives to better
man it is their risk and generate yield
and create Structured Products so we're
seeing more and more sophistication
around that secondly we're seeing I
believe we will see
um centralized exchange uh orders start
to move much more on chain to
decentralize exchanges and to lending
protocols uh like Ave maker compound
um where people have can custody their
own assets and have better transparency
into the health of of the place that
they're doing business for example in
Ave you can see you know every
participant their Health Credit their
the health criteria of their position
and the you know every change that
happens
um to any of the liquidity pools from an
interest rate perspective and then the
people are people are incentivized to
clean up the systemic Risk by causing
liquidations so I think that this is
really positive for D5 and
um we will see more defy activity I
believe than less because that people
have lost a lot of trust in the
centralized exchanges and the beautiful
thing about digital assets and crypto is
that there is radical transparency that
does not exist in traditional financial
markets and it's players like Amber data
that are facilitating people to
understand exactly what is happening uh
in digital assets and and under
understand uh the opportunities and
quantify risk so for us we are already
have the deepest offering for um
on-chain data and D5 and have been
really focused on serving institutional
customers whether that be banking
proprietary trading
um you know hedge funds
um you know market makers you know fund
admins tax accounting compliance Etc
um we'll continue to be make the
investment and be the deepest for
understanding you know anybody's
participation
um in the D5 protocol what's happening
at the protocol level what's happening
at the governance level what you know
how does that impact my Holdings and how
do I account for those those things
um and then additionally we're building
out Market intelligence platform right
now
um to give a single Panda glass view of
what's Happening across every
centralizing training training venue all
the defy activity and really understand
uh what's happening
how about inside of the company how like
what is the
enthusiasm uh we're in the bottom of a a
crypto winter it appears are people uh
quitting are they leaving are you seeing
more applications like what are you guys
seeing inside of the company right now
yeah so in the company it's actually
it's
a little cocky to say but it's great
times where we're actually hiring from
quite a few of the firms that have that
have had unfortunate times
um we've uh hired from several of the
exchanges we've hired um our we just
hired a new VP of engineering who's a
world-class VP of engineering from
Voyager we've hired some quants out of
some of the funds that have blown up
it's been an amazing time we've we have
are incredibly well funded we are backed
by you know some of the leaders in Trad
fund as well as crypto and everybody's
telling us Now's the Time to build
lead-in lean in and um so we're just
ramping our engineering and our product
and our customer support and our sales
and go to market teams and and we're
really just taking advantage of the
opportunity to hire the best people and
really go out and be partners with
everybody that matters in this space so
they can they can position themselves
for when the next bull market comes in
everybody's plugged and played and ready
to go
I love it where can we send people able
to find you on the internet or find out
more about Amber data
yeah so uh you know amberdata.io or on
Twitter
um amberdale Amber data IO
um and uh
um we can provide a link in in the
webcast below to all of our our social
media handles amazing Sean thank you so
much for taking the time to do this uh
it's pretty incredible to see uh the
work you guys are doing kind of how
you're grabbing the data what you're
doing it from a synthesis a synthesizing
standpoint how you're presenting it to
customers uh we've all been working
together for quite a while now uh on
various uh things and and I think part
of what everyone agrees on in the
industry uh is the fact that you need
good data to make good decisions and uh
seeing the work that you guys are doing
there is pretty cool so thank you so
much for joining me and we will
definitely do this again in the future
thank you very much it was a pleasure to
be on the show